i have to play the hulkster
did you catch that
23 was it
hogan 2009
look at this
he's calling for it
those of you that are familiar with hulk
he's calling for a game right now
oh
everybody should be fearful i think um
is the assassin here on chess cube
i always seem to reference that
everybody should fear the assassin
this is another guy that everybody
should fear right now
hogan
hogan is coming right out and throwing
the orangutang at me
the polish
sikalski opening
all right what do you do in response to
the orangutan
wow
let's try this
now this is new to me it's called the
out flank variation apparently
my move right here is regarded as the
outflank variation
all right if you say so
the outflank
let's try this
ah what's happening here
what's going on
the h file is ready to be peeled open
if bishop b2 queen b6
and if a3 then a5 i think i was talking
about this recently because
i played b4 myself and i was talking
about how c6 and then the queen coming
out to b6 or a5 idea might be available
i need more development what better to
do with my king knight than go here
now what
i might want to try b5
looks a little silly
but i might want to do it i might want
to be a little bit silly d5 bishop here
give up my light square bishop and plant
my ponds on light squares might be good
let's go pond
be a contributor
contribute to the center
get out here bishop you know you want to
play the game
compromise pawn structure
i have
some
i have somewhat i have some experience
with this structure right here just this
group of puns
i also want to back up because i'm not
going to be so quick to give up my light
square bishop
because he might want to hang out here
and act as a defender
let's
go this pawn can become isolated real
soon
and uh that's what we're gonna have
happen here
aren't we so let's do this
and i want to do what
it's really open right here and guess
who is not happy about that
i'm not happy about that
because my king is still not doing
anything great
my dark scrub bishop could come out
maybe this was a foolish move waste of
time waste of time
or is it
this pond is going to be a target
i might want to just give them up though
who who cares about that pawn right
i care about them
um
if i do this then a3 is played and then
if i take the pawn i'm in a pin let's
not do that
so what do you do
if you play here the knight gives you a
problem
and if you play here well maybe that's
not so bad
okay with this i'm saying
let's go ladies
let the ladies come off we're about even
with time myself in the hulkster
the hulkster is calling for a game here
three
minutes 10 seconds a small time
advantage here small
um
what else what else what else what else
less than three be very scared
my bishop wants to be
be disruptive
be disruptive develop
the rook is hit
i might want to consider queenside
castle can you believe that
believe it
it might be a good idea
oh this is scary
i might want to just say you know what
who cares about the b-pawn let's focus
on this guy and get castled
and i think i do want to castle because
it's still a bit too oh
sorry if i got loud right there
that happens don't listen with
headphones i say that
once in a while so if i play here what
was uh sparking that those little oohs
was that my i could get my bishop here
and these rooks end up looking silly
so just do it if you're gonna don't talk
about it do it
how many of you were saying that quit
you're talking about it just do it whoa
talk about an unexpected move
white says no
i will fork your rook and i say you
could do that but i will get that a pawn
maybe there was something better
maybe there wasn't but i'm gonna go for
this because i'm seeing a clear way to
grab this a pun
it's official i got a pig on the second
and a wild past bee pun
now
this knight is ready to be pounced on
and i don't know if i like that
um
up pawn push my candidate moves
pawn push this is weak
so what
it can't be targeted
can it
rook here king here i get out of a pin
bishop takes pawn takes the pawns are
restored but
i don't have a past pawn anymore so
i think it's going to be all right
what's this night's future because i'm
ready to kick him away and then grab
that pawn okay we have a pressing
forward in the center i can no longer
rely upon my knight to defend my e5 pawn
it's my king that now needs to
play such a role and now
this square right here if it doesn't
have your attention it should
and now it shouldn't
because this is no longer support point
for a knight
so my plan here this is a pass pawn now
with that last sequence of pawn
exchanges i want to take this knight out
and then push my c pawn to victory lane
touchdown square right here on c1
looking for the end zone
c5 c4 c3 c2 can i just do those back to
back to back like that
or is that a little bit too uh
silly for me to be thinking i could do
such a thing i don't think so i'm okay
with parting with my light square bishop
as a rule capture towards the center
unless you have a good reason not to
guess what
i do not have a good reason not to run
with that let's go i don't have a good
reason not to continue to push forward
with my past pawn and i still don't have
a good reason to not continue forward
with this pass pawn
in fact it could turn out to be
connected past pawns in a blink
right
the d-pawn is going to be an animal
two pawns on the third rank
or
yeah two black pawns on the third
or two white pawns on the sixth
usually do what they translate into
a rook
king up
king position
the king is a fighting piece be a
fighter
pawn push
rook here attack the pawn
let's go puns
and
what next
okay now is the time here now is the
time for just one accurate move
i'm just checking something out here
okay i just i could play all the way
back to the corner if i play here the
rook has to play behind it
i'm just
i'm just going to play here
yeah i'm going to play to the corner
and now i'm ready to just push here push
here and then score
there's nothing that can be done
right
these guys are very strong this one
right here that way i could play here
and shoulder off the king
no good solution i'm pretty sure there's
just no good solution so
i think i just keep pushing
two different queens
enough time to convert it
definitely enough time unless there is
the comcast gambit
i'm gonna give that up
i'm up a rook in this resulting position
actually wait
what was more accurate is to maybe throw
in a check or something but
however you slice it that was gonna be
good all right good game let me back up
and let's see about what
let's see about how either one of us
could have uh
done otherwise here um
interesting interesting opening this is
this is the second game in a row now
where i think i'm just
i've never seen it before
just like three moves in
um
so what's the scoop here
be aware of this idea in response to b4
i think it's
it's maybe best
the c6 this very calm move c6 allowing
for this a5 or queen b6 idea
um
so i mean now there's
you know this is a potential target but
we enter a structure right here where i
don't know if i should have uh
been able to get away with things like i
did
so i think this is what what can we say
about this position
the rook move i think was good
right here to b1 and i was starting to
feel comfortable right now as soon as
the rook went here
so this is
is there something better
first and foremost right now something
other than rook to b1
seems right but after this what about
maybe instead of taking the queen what
about rook to b2
something tells me you definitely have
to keep pressure on this weak point
otherwise i have very little worry so i
wonder if just
immediately responding to the bishop
threat
or
capturing the queen and then rook to b2
i like rook to b2 right here
rook b2 and then
you know because because um what are the
differences between the two you know do
you play queen takes and then rook b2
or just rook b2 right away i think you
just play rook b2 right away reason for
this is because you're not helping black
develop their dark square bishop
so rook to b2 is probably an improvement
right here and i don't know as a
follow-up what i would really have i
have to be cautious about my king side
structure i also have to be cautious
about
giving up let's say my light square
bishop
if the queens are still going to be on
the board because i'm i'm considering
this guy as a key defender for my
eventual kingside castle position
so i i i i turn out to be better here
and the alternatives i guess the rooks
have to go to sad squares
so maybe
actually you have to go to e1 or f1 to
maintain material if you play here then
it's uh it's actually trapped so the
rooks the decision at this point e1 f1
or to go in for the variation
knight to b5 which is allowing me to get
a pawn
so i don't know those earlier points the
the rook to b2 move maybe that's just a
very small
but important uh improvement there
uh who knows for sure though
uh all right
let me close out good game hogan
and uh
let's get another one in here